I want
to start in Ukraine
this hour, where officials say
the capital was the target
of a particularly intense air assault.
Well, that barrage of Russian
missiles lit up the skies over Kiev.
But Ukraine says
it intercepted all of them,
along with a number of drones, Russian.
Russia, however, claims
all of its targets were hit,
including a US Patriot
air defense system.
Meantime,
the head of the Russian mercenary
volunteer group says an American citizen
has been killed fighting
in the eastern flashpoint
city of Bermuda.
Ukrainian forces are claiming
substantial gains on the outskirts there.
See, there's some colleagues
joining us from southeastern Ukraine.
And I want to start,
if we can,
with a frightening night
for residents of Kiev.
An attack
launched some from the north,
the south and the east.
This was largely a failure,
but it was a noisy night Tell us
what we are learning
about what
happened overnight and how that plays
into the trajectory of this war.
At this point, some
Well, Becky,
I think the key issue here
and you put it in your intro,
very accurate, accurately,
accurately,
was the intensity of the attacks on Kiev.
This is a new tactic.
We have seen the Russians in the past use
mass formations
across many different cities,
many different targets.
Combining cruise missiles
and swarms of the Iranian made shahid
so-called drones.
They're actually unguided, slow moving
missiles
This time, though,
there was a focus of attention
on overwhelmingly on Kiev
and the amount of time
that the missiles were fired
within was very truncated.
This wasn't spread over many hours.
It was clearly an attempt
to try to find a chink in the air
defenses of the Ukrainian capital
by firing cruise
missiles, caliber missiles
to conventional missiles
and the kinds of the hypersonic
so-called hypersonic missiles,
all the more or less.
At the same time, that intent
there was clearly to try to overwhelm
the air defenses
and they failed significantly.
Also, the Ukrainians are claiming
that they shot down six Kenzo missiles.
That would bring a total of seven
that they say
that they have shot down now.
These were,
according to the Russians,
supposed to be invulnerable
to conventional or traditional
or contemporary air defenses.
Because of the speed
at which they travel.
But we're learning
now that they are actually not much more
sophisticated than many other
similar missiles
that are in the armories,
particularly of naito countries
that often hit hypersonic speeds
as they descend.
And also
their guidance systems
are pretty primitive to nonexistent
so they are not precision
missiles in the way that a cruise missile
might be.
We've got no evidence whatsoever
either to support the Russian claim,
the Patriot missile, anti-missile
missile batteries
were destroyed
in terms of the trajectory of all this.
Becky,
I think that what we're seeing here
is efforts being made by the Russians
to try to counterattack
and get inside the command
and control systems of the Ukrainians
ahead of their much vaunted
ground offensive, Becky.
Yeah, and that
ground offensive,
of course, is one
that we are anticipating
and no real detail
being released on that
and perhaps understand the body.
So the Vogler Group
playing
a very significant role in this war
on the Russian side
particularly in the fight for back.
Now, the head of that mercenary group
claiming that a US
citizen has died fighting in back mud
What do you make of this claim?
Well, the Russian
mercenary group Viognier
has released the video,
which it purports to be from
May the 16th of
if it goes in its leader in Burma.
But it's certainly in a town
that appears to be
the scene of some fighting.
There is background
noise of what might well be mortars.
That's what we hear.
One of the soldiers on the front
say one of the
Wagner mercenaries, rather,
he's inside a building.
He then comes across
the body of what he claims
is an American soldier,
including the identity documents.
Now, there's no word
yet from the US State Department,
and obviously we would not be
releasing a name for this
person until we have official
confirmation of who he is
and what the circumstances were.
But what's interesting
quite telling about this video
is that he's quite British.
Prigozhin is quite respectful
toward the dead soldier
that was killed on the fighting
on the Ukrainian side.
Whoever he is
saying that he will be given due honors
and because he's assumed to be American
will be buried
or rather covered with an American flag
and his flag
and his remains
returned somehow to the United States
because he put up a fight
up until the last, Prigozhin said.
So quite an intriguing statement
from an otherwise rather
contemptuous individual,
perhaps I suppose not unconnected
to the fact that he may fear
that he could be returning
one day to Moscow to face treason charges
if the US intelligence documents
are accurate.
In suggesting
that he allegedly
attempted to sell out
his Russian comrades
to sell their locations
to the Ukrainian US
in return for a softer ride
for his own fighters in parliament.
Not that many months ago, Becky,
some colleagues in south eastern Ukraine,
good to have you some time
there just after six in the evening.
Thank you.
Well, decades after Rosie
the Riveter
became a cultural icon
in the United States,
symbolizing the working
women of World War Two women in Ukraine.
All taking on similar roles.
They are increasingly doing jobs
Ukrainian men had to abandon
when they were called
into military service.
CNN's Nic Robertson with this report.
In a man's world, war is changing.
Everything Tatiana is at the vanguard
for shattering Ukrainian coal
mining history.
A woman on her way to work
a thousand feet underground.
It's normal or it's okay now.
Yes. Yes, it's good.
It's good.
If you wake up
I thought you wanted to be a miner.
Yes. Yeah.
Your family,
your grandfather, your father.
Yeah. Yeah.
She used to work aboveground,
but when miners got called up
to fight
and martial law cleared women
for dangerous jobs,
she jumped at a job deep in the mine.
Was this adequate to you?
As I always wanted to work here,
but girls were not allowed.
When many men were conscripted.
The mine had to keep working.
So to protect our country,
the girls stepped up.
She works six hour shifts, three days on.
One day off earns more than previously
and wants
to keep her underground job
when the war is over.
My work is not physically difficult.
I like it a lot.
I would like to continue working here
in this bastion
of MALE-DOMINATED tradition
that may not be so easy.
The other winners, though,
I think when the war is over
and we will win,
I think women will return
about the ground and the women's jobs.
Yet even Chief Engineer
Alexander admits
without Tatiana and many other women,
the mine could not have kept going.
Around 700 of our miners
got called up to fight.
Our women wanted to help both the mine
and the country.
So far,
46 women are working under the ground
alone.
There hasn't
been a general mobilization of women,
but plenty of traditional
male only workplaces are finding women
stepping up and taking jobs there.
Before the war
would have only gone to men
Maria is among them.
For the love of Ukraine
and of her husband.
Yes.
Now I know this theory
but the practice turned out
to be a little hotter.
She took up his blacksmith job
when he got called up to fight.
Last year,
they bought the forge together
a few years earlier,
invested their future in it.
But since
this is my husband's
passion and his life's business,
I decided to support him
to keep his job alive while he's serving.
She shows me a video of husband Andre
working at the same anvil
Pre-War his artwork.
Some Game of Thrones
themed selling in the US
and Europe for hundreds of dollars.
She is focusing on simpler stuff,
ornate kebab skewers and.
I very often cry in the porch here.
My husband is defending us
and that is very dangerous.
But this work helps me to hold on
and not fall apart.
Women have been here before.
Remember Rosie the Riveter icon of women
at work in World War Two.
She and others cracked the glass ceiling.
More than a hint of Rosie and
Maria and perhaps have changes here, too.
It's tiring work, but it's interesting.
I would like to do it
when I feel like it,
not what I have to do it.
Maria Tatiana,
two of many who bravely stepped up,
no doubt more challenges ahead.
Nic Robertson, CNN, in a coal mine,
eastern Ukraine.